bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to the Dean
show and we greet you with the greetings
that are the best of greetings Jesus
greeted his followers with peace Moses
Abraham and all the messages of God and
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and we always have an exciting
show for you and today's not an
exception because we have our guests all
the way from Bosnia Bosnia we want to
know a little bit about Bosnia they got
a lot of Muslims there people think Oh
Bosnia has the Arab bride in a desert
turkeys this that and you know we got
some Caucasian wisely and blue eyes and
we're gonna learn about them today with
our special guest doctor race Mustafa
cherish the Grand Mufti of Bosnia we'll
be right back
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam peace be
with you please be with you - how are
they how are you dr. grace most of the
charities how they do it very good very
good to see you III thank you so much I
know you're very busy now many of us are
busy but Jack's too busy you visit us
here in America and you did like a tour
of how many mustards ah that's right by
five when you going back to Bosnia
tomorrow right shop tomorrow thank you
so much may God Almighty the creator
Allah rewards you for finding the time
to be with us thank you very much nice
being in Chicago you know the Deen show
is dedicated to help clear the many
misconceptions the false fallacies that
people have is a lot of Islamophobia out
here and we're trying to show people
what Islam is really about Islam is
really about you know sharing his
message of peace with the world you know
so people such as yourself who are out
there you know in the media people look
up to you and we want to get some of
your advice many people think that Islam
is something that is an Arab riding into
the desert you know has you know
connotations with terrorism and all
these other things so when they tune in
and they hear what we have to say
they're like you know what it's not that
bad
and many people accept it so but now
when we mentioned Bosnia some people
have never for our American viewers
they've never heard of Bosnia so we're
gonna get a little lesson for you today
can you tell us we've heard this word
Bosniaks Bosnia what is this well I
don't know whether we can tell the story
about Bosnia a story of 1,000 years of
Bosnian history of which is 600 years of
Islam and this year we are celebrating
eleven centuries of Bosnian statehood
and the Bosnian history of
multiculturalism multi tolerance of
different religions traditions languages
and so on but when we come to Islam we
want to remind your viewers that all the
religions that claim divinely inspired
revelations came from the east and even
the Sun is rising from the east as we
know so the three Abrahamic religions
that claim the source of the book the
rod taurah and injeel the gospel and the
Quran which are the first covenant
covenant the second covenant and the
last covenant so the prophets of Adam
Abraham knew Abraham Ibrahim know moose
is and Muhammad peace be upon all of
them these prophets made history or may
changes in the humanity all all these
prophets are the common ground and
common share of Islam Christianity in
Judaism now if we said that all
religions came from the east that means
there was no prophet that God has sent
to Europe and there is no European
prophets they are all from the same area
which is the Middle East or Palestine or
Mecca as we know so there is no one
there is no geography priority for any
religion in Europe we are equal in the
geography returns
so we in the West or in Europe we're
waiting for the messages and messengers
who came from the east so some of us in
Europe did hear the message of is Musa
and some of us heard the message of the
Prophet Muhammad but they are all the
same historically we have these three
religions that are may named by judea
christianity by the person ASA and
Judaism also by a hood but Islam is not
named by a person it is named by a
abstract idea which contains the very
meaning of peace because the root of
Islam came from seeing meme Lomb which
means peace so Islam means peaceful
submission to God and Muslim means
peaceful man literally now we can talk
later
why how it happened that the Muslim
became the just the opposite to this now
when we come to talk about Islam and
Europe we have to remember that Islam as
Christianity and Judaism arrived in
Europe at a certain time in certain
conditions first in the beginning of a
century in the Iberian Peninsula which
is the Spain or the the old name is
called Andalusia and it lasted for eight
centuries in 1492 both the Christian
what the Muslims and Jews were expelled
and why you by the way the Christians
who have been expelled from the Iberian
Peninsula in 1492 arrived in to Sarajevo
and were received by Muslims and saved
by Muslims together with their Passover
book called
the Haggadah which is known now as the
Sarajevo Haggadah so I am proud as a
grandchild of my grand grandfather's who
did not they didn't they were not afraid
of universal declaration of human rights
they did were not afraid of the
so-called international Watchers for the
violation of human rights but they acted
on the basis of the religion Islam and
they helped the Jews who were expelled
from Christian from Spain or Andalusia
at the time now when Islam ended his
mission in the Iberian Peninsula the
light of Islam was a candle in the
Balkan Peninsula which is the 14th
century and it has arrived in into
Bosnia Herzegovina in 1463 where the
Bosnia acts they are called dobry
Bostian or the good version acts have
accepted Islam in totality and
especially noble Bosnian families
because previously they were practicing
dualism of religion and they were not
very prone of the clergy and when islam
came they he it was introduced to them
as a natural religion that they accepted
so from that time until now we have
Islam inversely Herzegovina with the
rich tradition now before we go to break
I heard an interesting story now tell me
is this true that at one point in time
you had those who are following christ
jesus peace be upon him who no Muslim is
a Muslim unless he believes in
he was one of the mightiest messengers
of God correct now at this point they
were in this region and they were called
what I was what I was told and and will
you take off from here bogel means that
they didn't accept God being three and
eternity or God being a man they only
wanted to worship the Creator and not
the creation and when Islam came to
submission to the will of God they
accept it wholeheartedly is this true
well I wouldn't say definitely
definitely about it very translated but
bhaga means they they they were the
people who practice their own religion
within the frame of Christianity at the
time with a particular interpretation of
the of Christianity which did not
understand very well Trinity as such so
we can we can say that bogu means were
treated as heresy at the time because
they were not fully with the in
accordance with what what he can was
teaching and preaching they were holding
on to unitarianism Holly the only one
yes and that's what mom is all about the
belief in one God we'll be right back
with more with Grand Mufti
dr. race most of the cherries here on a
Dean show you say that you're not
believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of his name you can not be a
Muslim that ended our faith to believe
in and love Jesus Christ
I would say this thing that you just
told me it's not in the scripture and
they would say a marginal note added by
scribe yeah okay we know that and I'd be
thinking if you know this is not the
Bible why are you preaching it as if
it's gospel truth and if we're gonna
worship something I figured I might as
well worship the Creator instead of any
of the creations now in upon
investigating the villages remember find
another meaning of what Islam is what
Muslim is those who surrender their self
to God is a Muslim those who surrender
submit to God God's will that is Islam
was pure it was just you just praise her
God
back here on the Dean show with the
Grand Mufti doctor race most of the
chairs now for some people that they
don't know you know when we say Grand
Mufti can you tell us a little bit you
know about yourself and what are some of
your tasks and your roles that you
perform back in Bosnia and all over the
world actually
the Grand Mufti is known to all Muslims
who he is the you know the mufti is the
first Muslim intellectual the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was the mufti
and the mufti is the one who is
spreading the knowledge and education
and he is professing to the pupils and
students and people about certain ideas
and in this case Mufti is an
intellectual who is shaping the minds of
people who want to listen and to seek
advice from him so the difference
between the mufti and the kadhi is that
the mufti is the man of the opinion he
is the man of intellect of
intellectualism why the kadhi is the one
who is implementing by force some of the
fatwa that are issued by Mufti so the
mufti is the one who has known the power
who doesn't have the power of execution
he has the power only of teaching
educating and spreading goodwill among
the people and giving the advice upon
the the question on on about the issue
so the Grand Mufti is the spiritual
source or reference for the Muslim who
wants to know about his religion
properly in all aspects of religious
life whether it is
the warship or legal opinions or the
social issues even political issues so
in in in my case the Grand Mufti of
Bosnia Herzegovina or the title of the
aluminum to the highest authority
religious Islamic Authority for the
Muslim community in Boston has the
governor sanjak or Serbia Croatia
Slovenia and partly the Montenegro
so the Islamic Authority that is
stationed in Boston has the governor the
heck to headquarter of is not only for
Bosnia but also for all Bosniaks in
particular in bosnia herzegovina and
outside so why this institution is very
important it is important because we our
fathers and grandfathers have adopted
Hannity mishap and according accordance
to the hanafi madhhab the Juma prayer is
not valid without the permission or the
license of the Khalifa or the suit on
since we don't have now Khalifa the
after the building Congress when was
near was annexed by the austro-hungarian
Empire the Sheikh who Islam of Istanbul
issued a measure the document by way of
which he legitimized for the Muslim
community that they can have their the
own religious had super supreme had in
Western Herzegovina that will take the
responsibility of Khalifa or or
the suit on meaning that he will the
issue ijazah late license to each and
every Imam and each and every fatigue to
be able to preach Islam in the mask so
that we don't go astray and do not
misrepresent Islam and miss preach so
this is why we are investing ethical in
the United community this is why we are
institutionalized and this is why we are
uniformed and we don't have any
religious this this disturbance are
based on internal Muslim interests that
you have for example in other places
because we are very disciplined in that
so my responsibility as can move team by
the merit of receiving the measure is
that Muslims gave me the authority to
execute or to apply the Sharia rules
that are connected to the way we are
worship worshiping the way we are
teaching our religion which is based on
peace and tolerance and understanding of
each other and that's what Islam is all
about Islam says love all mankind that's
why we shared because we care and we
want to get this message out to the
world because purpose of life you know
everybody has that god-given right to
know why is migrated where they're going
when they died and what is pleasing to
the crater so we as those who obviously
have children to submit only to God
worshipping the crater not a stick not a
stone not a man not a monkey not
elephant no one but the creator and not
his creation and following the teachings
of the last and final messenger the same
way if we were living during the time of
Jesus we would have followed been
following him or Moses or a man but it
just so happens to be that problem Hamid
is the last and final messenger so
doesn't matter if you're Italian Greek
Serbian Croatian if you want to submit
to God you can submit to God and be a
Muslim but tell us now in that neck of
the woods and that in that region here
you know some sad events happened
you know there was a genocide and people
who were declaring that I just want to
worship God who were living as Muslims
you know a people know it was it was
war-torn Bosnia it we used to be
Yugoslavia than the split up can you
tell adjust and briefly what's going on
to prevent something like that happy
that sad event that innocent men women
and children were being killed
how can people be more aware to create
awareness of this to prevent this from
ever it happened like 11 times is that
true to prevent it from happening for
the 12-time we're almost out of time so
I'm sure what can people do you know and
like I said we got love for all mankind
so we want the best for everybody but we
just want people to be aware so we can
try to help this prevent this from
happening again what everyone can do a
lot too but I can speak what Muslims
should do first of all we have Iman
which is the notion of security inside
so the movement the the the one who is a
trustworthy who is spreading the
security outside in the public sphere is
the one who has the security and self
confidence in himself so first of all
you have to be clear in your mind which
means that the tolerance comes as a sign
of strength intolerance is the sign of
your weakness so if you know who you are
you know your identity you know the
purpose of life and you know the value
of humanity and the human beings you
have no need to be intolerant to others
you are on the contrary you like to see
different people living with you and you
sharing sharing your experience now once
we establish our self confidence in our
mind in our heart then islam teaches us
that you have to spread the peace and
muslim is that islam means submission
but this is not a full
meaning of Islam Islam means peaceful
submission
there cannot be submission by compulsion
this is why we have this principle in
Islam like 15 there is no compulsion in
religion this is the this was the
historic affirmative action in eighth
century that Islam wrote to to the to
the mankind so when we say Islam is the
prime submission we have to add all the
time
that it is peaceful submission and the
Muslim means literally a peaceful man
now how it became that the Muslim not
every terrorist is but every Muslim is a
terrorist but every terrorist is a
Muslim you're on what's going on yeah
yes this is this is partly Muslims are
responsible themselves and partly
because Muslims are hated by some people
without any reason so we cannot change
those who hate Islam and Muslims but we
can change ours we ourselves so that
means we should not do foolish things
and then damage the meaning of Islam and
we should learn that only God accept
your religion if you are accepting it
peacefully and your submission to God if
it is peaceful God will accept it
because God Himself is a Salam he is
peace himself so if you force somebody
to become a Muslim this is why we have
this statement in the Quran like I have
15 it came as a result because one
person one father came to the prophet
and said I I forced my son to accept
Islam from Christianity and Prophet
Muhammad told him no you should not do
this because God told you that there is
no compulsion in Islam and then finally
we have this concept of a son which came
from the world hasent which means beauty
so
and when prophet was asked what is asan
he said and to mean a bit like and look
at who were in lambda alpha Iraq the Sun
which is righteousness which is well
well-being which is good and goodness
means that you should worship God as if
you see him because if you don't see God
God sees you so that means your
righteousness must come from your
motivation that you do this not because
people praises you only but because God
is seeing you what you are doing and
therefore you are a beautiful you are
smiling you are spreading the peace and
security around the world because God is
appraising you for that not because
somebody is going to write that you are
violating human rights no because God is
pleased that what you are spending the
kindness the goodness the peace the
security around the world now this is
what we Muslims have to learn and this
is what we Muslims have to teach others
about our religion security Iman peace
al-islam and beauty goodness
righteousness al-assad Sheikh we'll take
a break and we'll be right back to close
it up don't go anywhere we'll be right
back everybody in deep down they believe
that there is a god yes and as much as
they deny
if God exists and he does if God sends
prophets and he does if God reveals
books and he does should he not tell me
how to live my life doesn't that make a
sense they feel more secure and safe now
inside the religion of Islam than they
ever felt out in the streets
but the best way to bring true profound
happiness trooper found peace trooper
found tranquility is by following the
guidance that God has given see for
yourself what Islam has to say because
it really is the path to happiness and
truth in life running this universe he
doesn't it doesn't make sense
who is jesus worshipping as this is
recorded in the gospels despite all of
the other issues about the gospel we put
those aside with the saints mentioned
with jesus
I am Not Afraid to stand alone get four
lines by my side I am Not Afraid
back here on the Dean show thank you for
tuning in thank you again for being with
us we have just a few more questions
that I want to ask you I'm gonna go off
on a tangent real quick have you ever
had a chance you know I listen to you
talk also in Bosnian I speak broken
Bosnian but I understand better and it's
very nice to hear you listen you really
get the people comfortable you gave my
leg a laughing you're serious also at
the same time have you ever had a chance
to sit I'm sure you have but with some
atheist people don't believe in God and
how do you like refute this or how do
you deal have you dealt with an atheist
someone who just like you know what
they're confused or they say I don't
believe in God what do you like to tell
me is what I don't believe that there
are people who don't believe there is a
book recently was released that about
the face of faceless you know there are
no people that don't have faith because
you see even in the language when we say
taste an atheist what is 80s the 80s is
the one who is denying faith so how can
you deny something if it doesn't exist I
mean you you deny you have you can deny
something that is already exists so when
we when we have to change the the
perception of an atheist and but we know
that there are people who are not sure
about the existence of God and they are
called Gnostics agnostics organist ixora
austex that means that those who would
think that this is not possible to know
whether God exists or not and therefore
they are indifferent or they don't want
to tackle this but on the other hand if
if you mean somebody who who is
disputing with you about your faith I
think you should be patient about it it
is level as it were on to us
if if somebody faced you like
challenging your faith you should
say to him Salam and you should walk
humbly and just go you in your way and
God has told us that and Halleck not
confirming come carefully Famicon
kumoemon God has created all men and
some of them are believers belong
disbelievers and some of them believers
so we humans freedom to choose if they
are but the freedom of choice for in
Islamic understanding is not your
freedom to choose an evil you have a
freedom to choose a higher you have
freedom to choose good which this is why
in Islam if TR is came from the world
higher which means good so we are free
to choose this way or other way and
because of that we are responsible
because if you don't have free freedom
to choose by your own will then how can
you be responsible so if when I talk
with somebody who does not share with my
religion I appreciate his thoughts I can
listen to him I disagree with him and
also he has right to that disagree with
me with me but I also feel that I am
enriched by by his by talking to him
because he is giving me chance to check
my faith my faith and to strengthen my
argument against those who are trying to
confuse me and to challenge my argument
so God has created all humanity let
Malcolm endocrine most are female and
main so that we may know each other and
we may know teach each other and remain
learning from each other before come of
course before we come to an end we know
that for a long time you know the
creator of the heavens and earth in the
verbatim word of God
and tells us to be united we have the
Koran unchanged on temper temper free
tamper-proof for 1,400 years has been
there preserved memorized by millions
it's a living miracle and we have the
way the Sunnah of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind so we hold
fast to that we strive our best to be
committed to it now you've heard us
being called Mohammed ends at one time
all those are the Turks oh all these
names and labels being put up and the
media trying to divide and you've heard
a new term coming up it's called some we
vyv Wahhabi shabi something like that
have you heard this term can you clarify
have you heard this also this term and
what is this all about well it is how do
you say will he be you see because this
is this is very complicated question to
answer but is there such a thing
what if you want to be straightforward
yeah
you have you do your way straight
forward there are different people who
see different things so I am I I am NOT
obsessed or I'm not I don't have time to
think about all these kind of different
names of different people I for Muslim
for myself I know that I am Muslim for
Muslim and I know what it means but at
the same time I am Bosnia so we have
multiple identities I am at the same
Muslim Bosniaks Bosnian European and you
name it
then I can associate to my village to my
town and all this but what is important
that it is each of these identities that
are clear in your mind so they are not
excluding each other they are inclusive
so you you you have different identities
multiple data entities but each identity
you put priority some put religion
some put nationalities and put it licit
example I mean mess have different
school teaching and so on what is
important that you do not become
aggressive Noga that you don't become
exclusive that you don't endanger other
people and you don't provoke other
people by your identities but you take
this as something which is yours and
then you love your identities but you
respect the oddities of others and
therefore it isn't indecision not
anything particular about Muslims to
have different opinions about all other
religions cultures traditions and as we
say as we are told in by the a tradition
that Allah Almighty Rahman the
differences of my own that is a mercy is
something that should give us the
creativity and competition in Buddha's
and so on and so on so we cannot have
unified the world because if God wanted
he he could create us to be one in
everything one religion one color one
this but he created us so colorful so
different so we have to enjoy this
diversity in the unity so there's no
such thing as a [ __ ] there's no
such thing I've heard you say this in an
interview so there's no such thing as
this name and people shouldn't call each
other names I shouldn't call your name
you shouldn't call me a name we should
be loving kind merciful toward each
other so we shouldn't divide each other
so there's no such thing as a will he be
Wahhabi yeah
there's no such thing well you see there
are some people I heard you say before
that there is it who are giving labels
of different kinds so I don't want to
get into this with this mass if you like
now I I just want to say that for those
who want to know about Islam and Muslims
that there is only one legitimate
named for all of us and that is Muslim
the the the first the one who was called
first time in the history was Ibrahim
alayhi salatu wassalam
so we are I am a Muslim in the sense of
the not National sense but in the sense
that I am willingly and peacefully are
submitting or obeying or listening to
the will of God and this is what is the
meaning of my understanding of my
religion and being a Muslim
so we're once were submitted to the will
of God was Jesus a Muslim Abraham was a
man Abraham Mohammed all these
messengers was once who submitted to the
will of God anyone anyone who is
peacefully submitting himself it was the
will of God we can call him by a general
meaning a Muslim so we're muscle and the
whole universe is a Muslim because the
whole evil universe is submitted to the
will of God and the universe that laws
the physical laws that God has put into
the function these physical laws are
functioning power and our Quran
willingly or unwillingly by God's will
so the whole universe is a Muslim in the
sense of a peaceful or submission to the
will of God because in the final
analysis we our beginning comes from God
and we will return to God all of us
whether we know it or not closing
comments or suggestions for all the
millions who are tuning in to the Deen
show and for our brothers in humanity
any closing comments and suggestions
that you have for Humanity may God bless
you all and give you the will for
peaceful submission to God's mercy and
blessings may God Almighty the Creator
Allah reward you for being very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode on the Dene show and we had our
special guest Gangu Mufti of Bosnia and
that's the message we're all Muslims
we're once were submitted to the will of
God you could be a Muslim Jesus was a
Muslim Abraham was a Muslim nor was a
Muslim
the son is a Muslim all of the things
around you that are submitted to God I'm
Muslim so you can call us right here
1-866 to Islam if you like we have to
say send us your feedback your comments
to get a free copy of the verbatim Word
of God
call us
this is the theme